abone ol
bu Merhabalar hayatımızda bir komut
gerçeği var ve bu sebeple Sizinle böyle
bir sanal ortamda bir araya gelmemiz
ancak uygun oldu ama Mesafeler
hiçbirimize engel değil bu sebeple
müsaadelerinize Ben maskemi mankene
devrediyorum mankende de isimden
gördüğünüz gibi benim antartikada giymiş
olduğum kıyafeti Taşıyan mankene maskemi
teslim ederek sizlerle Önümüzdeki süreç
içinde bir arada olmak istiyorum Bu
sunumda artık bir rol model
bu olma fikriyle sizlerle bir ara dayım
artık bir rol model fikri ilk olarak
aklıma Aslında Antartika hikâyesinde
Kendimi nasıl bulduğumda alakalı Bu
sebeple geçireceğimiz vakit içerisinde
size bu konu hakkında bir şeyler
anlatmak istiyorum şu mantar tikada
yaklaşık 14 15 senedir çalışmalar yapan
bir bilim insanıyım özellikle iklimsel
değişimler iklim değişikliği küresel
ısınma olarak ifade lendir dediğimiz
kavramların içinde Kutup kavramları çok
net duyuyoruz doktora çalışmam esnasında
ki bu bizi 2005 yılına götürüyor Doktor
hocam da ilk konuşmamı sizlere aktarmak
istiyorum
bu Antartika çalışmalarıma ilk nasıl
başladım bunu özellikle anlatmak
istiyorum Doktor hocamla hangi konuyu
çalışırım ne tarz konular üzerinde
çalışmalar yapabiliriz hangisi benim
Özellikle çalışma konsantrasyonumu
arttıracak konu olur diye bir araya
geldiğimizde hocamın bana ilk sorduğu
şey şuydu Burcu O harita mühendisiyim
tabi uzaktan algılama çalışıyorum
uydularla yeryüzüne yüzeye baktığımız be
ulaşamadığı mızrak noktalarda bize bolca
veri aktaran uydu görüntüleriyle ilgili
tecrübem hem lisanslı hem yüksek
lisanslı mevcut Doktora da devam etmek
üzerine tabi bütün kurgu hocam bana şu
şekilde ifade etti dedi ki hani uzaktan
algılama verileriyle marşı
o uzay abla adapte olabiliriz ya da
küresel iklim değişikliği var dünya
yeryüzü dünyamızda bir çalışma yapmak
istersen de Antartika konusu var tabi
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde doktorun
başlamak için girişimde bulunmuştum
Şöyle bir düşündüm uzay teknolojisinde
bile hala İster Amerika olsun ister
Rusya Hani dünyanın bu konuyu çalışan
ülkeleri bile hala bir Mars'a insan
gönderemedi ya da işte uzayda insan ayak
izinin varlığı söz konusu değil benim de
uzay çalışmamda ki uzaktan algılamada
şöyle bir durum vardır yersen ölçüleri
yaparsınız uydu verileriyle de aynı
bölgeye çalışıp uydu görüntülerini
doğruladıktan sonra evet uydu
görüntüleri çok doğru veriler veriyor
doğru
oy veriyor artık ben sadece uydu
görüntüleriyle çalışabilirim deme
şansımız oluyor Böylece tek bir yer Sen
ölçüm ve bol bol uzaktan algılama
verileriyle bu çalışma mümkün oluyor
Şöyle bir düşündüm Tabii dedim ki
Antartika hala mümkün uzay
çalışmalarında iki yıl 2005'ten
bahsediyoruz tabi uzay çalışmaları hala
istenilen noktalara gelmedi altı artık
ya Büyük ihtimalle benim için çalışma
konusunda söz konusu olabilir tercih
Hocama yaklaşık bir iki dakika
düşündükten sonra ilettim o günden sonra
antartika'ya çalışmaya başladım ama mars
için düşündüğüm işte Mars'a gidilir
gidilmez antartika'yı da gitme hayalini
o an hocam benimle konuşurken kurdum ama
Antartika gitmekte o kadar kolay değil
hatta Mars ile gidecek ya da uzaya
gönderilecek bilimi
Hı hı hazırlıkları da antartikada
yapılıyor Yani aslında yeryüzünün bırak
uzak noktasından bahsediyoruz tabi
doktora öğrencisi olarak bak
araştırmalara başladım o konuda bilimsel
çalışmalar yapmış olan bilim insanları
ile kontak kurmaya başladım Çünkü
aslında bir bilim insanı dediğinizde
araştıran sorgulayan ortaya konmuş
çalışmalardan bazı öngörülerde bulunan
bir yapı ortaya koymanız gerekiyor bilim
insanlarıyla koordinasyonu geçtim kendi
doktora hocamla Çalışmalara başladı ama
yaklaşık altı ay boyunca çok ciddi
araştırmalar işte kimler gitmiş ne tarz
bilimsel çalışmalar yapmış ben ne
çalışabilirim tabi arkada antartika'yı
görüyoruz bir tarafta da bizim Türk
bilim üstünü geçici kampımızı kurduğumuz
hor şu Adası'nı görüyoruz 2005 yılında
ben tabi bu
O hep hayal ederek Ben o an Amerika'da
asla Tüm imkanları daha rahat Antartika
konusunda imkanları olan bir ülkede
doktora çalışması yaparken bile bu kadar
zorluklar yaşadım Türkiye'de o dönem
direkt Türkiye'den doktora çalışması
yapmış yüksek lisans lisans ya da bilim
insanlarını zaten neredeyse yok denecek
kadar az olduğunu biliyoruz Amerika'da
ama yılmadım 6 ay boyunca çok ciddi
Çabalar sarf ettim konuyu seçmiş
olmamasına Bana çok büyük sorumluluklar
yükledim Antartika konusunda
çalışacaktım herkese yazdım
ulaşabileceğim insanlara yazdım Bence
öğrenci olmanın avantajı bu
bilmiyorsunuz öğrenmek istiyorsunuz ve
size en uzatan Bilim insanlarından
faydalanmak istiyorsunuz konumun Deniz
buz olması Deniz buz larının işte Zaten
halihazırda yıl 2
3.20 D ne kadar edildiğini biliyoruz
2005'te bu konuda çalışmak üzere bu
konuda çalışma yapmış Bütün bilim
insanlarına ulaşmak adına yazılarda
bulundum email üzerinden iletişimleri
iletişime geçtim schiemann sonunda
yaklaşık herhalde 6'ya da 8 Ayça
bağladıktan sonra Avustralya'da
tazmanya'da Deniz buzul ile ilgili bir
çalıştay yapılacağını ve bu çalıştaya
asla benim o kontak kurmaya çalıştım
Herkesin bir araya geleceği bilgisine
ulaştım ve hemen çalıştığım
koordinatörleri ne yazdım ben bir
doktora öğrencisiyim ve bizim bu
projemizin bütçesi olmadığı için
herhangi bir seyahat bütçemiz de yok ama
eğer bu konuda ciddi anlamda çalışan
bilim insanları bir araya gelmek
istiyorsan ki ben bunu istiyorum bu
fırsatı sizin yaratma imkanınız var mı
diye bir gün bile olmadı yani 24 saat
diliminin içine bile girmeden
avustralya'dan cevap geldi
Uğur Bey bunun mümkün olacağını Hatta
çalıştığı planlayan kişinin eş ya da
yardımcısının diyelim yardımcı Çalışlar
organizatörün benim bulunduğum
Amerika'da Teksas eyaletinde Selahattin
ya şehrindeki bir bilim insanı olduğunu
söyledi ve o kişiyi de iyiyim ile
eklediği için o kişinin dağında bilgisi
oldu diğer 24 saatlik dilimi içerisinde
o kişiden bana mesaj geldi ki Burcu bir
araya gelelim senin bu takımın içinde
nasıl olman gerektiği ile ilgili bir
konuşalım o konuşmanın üzerinden bir ay
sonra ben tazmanya'da NASA'dan ve diğer
bütün dünyanın Avrupa Amerika Güney
Amerika Kuzey Amerika Yeni Zelanda
Avustralya bilim insanları ve benim
Direkt çalışma konuyla ilgili çalışmalar
yapan bilim insanları ile bir araya
gelerek kendi yaptığım çalışmaları
anlattım ki zaten doktora öğrenci
O çok tıkandım bir nokta daydım getire
bildiğim noktaya kadar getirdim artık
bir uzman görüşü ihtiyacım vardı ve
karşımda nasıl yetkililer otururken Ben
onların uzaya fırlattığı uydu
görüntüleri ile ilgili hataları tabi
çatır çatır doktora öğrencisi olmanın
verdiği o rahatlıkla aktardım Tabi bir
yandan da pişman oldum Neticede böyle
büyük bir topluluğu karşısında nasa'daki
yetkililere onların fırlattığı uydu ile
ilgili hataları deklere etmem öğrenci
rahatlığıyla Aslında normalde Ama tabii
bir anlamda da İçinizde kuşku düşüyor ki
acaba ters algılanır mı diye aksine
nasıl yetkililer de ilk toplantı
arasında benim sunumdan sonra yanıma
gelerek nasa'da bu konuyu direkt yerinde
çalışmak ister misin Hey sen ortaya
O hataları Aslında kullanıcı tarafından
ortaya konulan hatalar bizim için
kıymetli ya da senin yaptığın bir hata
varsa biz de onu yerinde düzeltebiliriz
diye Nasıl ya Davet ettiler konuşmanın
başına tekrar gönderme yapmak istiyorum
Çünkü ben karşınıza rol model olma
sloganıyla çıktım var rol model olmak
istiyorum gençlerimize Eğer belirli bir
çalışma konusunda Tabii ki bu bilimsel
ya da merak ettiğiniz bir konu olabilir
Türkiye'nin faydasına yararına insanlık
faydasını ya dünyanın faydasına yararını
olduğunu düşündüğünüz ve sizin kafanızda
soru işaretleri var ya da dünya bunu
halihazırda cevap vermemiz Siz de o
konuyu çalışmak istiyorsunuz sorgulayın
sorun ulaşın iletişime geçin şunu
unutmayın iletişime geçtiğiniz herkesten
siz
bu gelmeyecektir ama ben kendimden örnek
verirsem de verecek veren şekilde devam
edeceğim edersem altı ila 8 ay boyunca
iletişime geçtiğim kişilerden dönen oldu
Dönmeyen olduğu ya da dönenler arasından
seçmem gerektiği ama sonunda doğru
buldum motivasyon kaybı yaşamış olsaydım
büyük ihtimalle Ben de averaj bu çalışma
düşük modlu bir çalışma çok büyük bir
soruna cevap veremeyecek bir çalışmayı
ortaya koyup yaptım çalışmanın da çok
arkasında durmayacaktım belki de o
çalışmaya hiç bitirebilecek Team sormak
sorgulamak bilimle olmak bilim insanı
olmak özellikle çalışma alanı olarak
belirlediğiniz ya da dünyanın sorunları
olarak değerlendirdiğiniz şeyleri
arkasından gitmekte fayda var ve
ulaştığını
Bu sorunun halihazırda çalıştığını
düşündüğünüz insanlara da ulaşmanın Z
çok büyük faydaları olacaktır Bu anlamda
rol model olmak istiyorum Benim hiçbir
zaman motivasyonum bozulmadı ve dünya
meselesi olarak düşündüğüm bir kolunun
belirli noktalara ve doğru noktalara
ulaştırılması için elimden geleni yaptım
elinizden geleni yapacağınıza eminim
inanıyorum ben sizlerin rol modeli
olmaya talibim Sizlerde başkalarının rol
modeli olacağınızı biliyorum